les États-Unis ont toujours su utiliser
leur poids économique pour aider quand
ils en avaient envie ou bloqué quand ils
en avaient besoin
et je pense que en suivant là encore
Alessandro on peut parler aujourd'hui de
capitalisme politique américain
ce capitalisme politique américain on en
a le programme c'est un discours de Jake
Sullivan prononcé le 16 septembre à la
remise du rapport du Special comme
positive je te dise project et ce
programme il a quatre axes
le premier c'est investir dans
l'écosystème scientifique et
technologique le deuxième c'est faire
émerger des talents le troisième c'est
protéger l'avantage technologique des
États-Unis et le quatrième c'est
approfondir les alliances et
partenariats investir dans l'écosystème
scientifique et technologie sur la
recherche c'est et Alice vous en parlera
mieux c'est
identifier définir des technologies
critiques et mettre en place des
soutiens par exemple il y a eu sous la
présidence Trump la National quantum
initiative pour faire le lien aussi avec
la sécurité il y a tout ce qui a découlé
de la National Security commission aïe
sur l'intelligence artificielle
c'est la recherche mais c'est aussi le
déploiement ça c'est les grands plans de
politique industriels de
l'administration Weiden le chips actes
pour les semis conducteurs et je crois
que c'est monsieur le Président du Sénat
qui en parlait lynchalation réduction
Act sur les technologies vertes
berger les talents c'est aussi des
subventions et des programmes qui sont
prévus dans le chips and science
protéger davantage technologie des
États-Unis c'est la sécurité économique
par exemple le fait que le FBI regarde
de plus en plus près les coopérations
entre les universités chinoises et les
centres de recherche américain ce qu'ils
ont appelé la China initiative c'est les
contrôles exports on a beaucoup parlé en
octobre avec des premiers contrôles qui
avaient été mis en place sous
l'administration Trump et qui ont été
renforcés pour empêcher l'exportation de
tout ce qui sert à faire des des puces
de dernière technologie notamment celles
qui sont utilisées pour faire tourner
des modèles d'intelligence artificielle
et dernière idée en date quelque chose
qui est en discussion et beaucoup de
discussions Washington autour d'un futur
exotyver sur un contrôle les
investissements quelque chose qu'on fait
en France et qu'on a fait en Europe mais
pas un contrôle les investissements
entrant il existe déjà c'est le comité
US ce qui va le faire c'est un contrôle
les investissements sortants pour éviter
des transferts de technologie
approfondir les alliances et
partenariats c'est introduire une
dimension technologique et sur les
chaînes d'approvisionnement dans toutes
les grandes alliances le titre ici avec
l'Europe le trident technology
des questions technologiques très
traitées au sein du quad l'alliance avec
l'Australie le Japon l'Inde et bien sûr
les États-Unis et l'internalisation des
contrôles export qu'on a vu avec un
accord avec le Japon les Pays-Bas et la
Corée du Sud